the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
and this last little bit is something
which is not yet on the web but anyway
when I was walking out of the room last
time I noticed that I'd written down the
wrong formula for c1 minus c2 there's a
misprint there's a minus sign that's
wrong I claimed last time that c1 minus
c2 was plus 1/2 but actually it's minus
1/2 if you go through the calculation
that we did with the antiderivative of
sine X cosine X we get these two
possible answers and if they're to be
equal then if we just subtract them you
get c1 minus c2 plus 1/2 is equal to 0
so c1 minus c2 is equal to 1/2 all right
so those are all of the Corrections
again everything here will be on the web
but I just wanted to make it all clear
to you all right
so here we are this is our last day of
the of the second unit applications of
differentiation and I have a one of the
most fun topics to introduce to you
which is differential equations and we
have a whole course on differential
equations which is called 1803 and so
we're only going to do just a little bit
but I'm going to teach you one technique
which fits in precisely with what we've
been going with what we've been doing
already which is differentials
the first and simplest kind of
differential equation is the rate of
change of X with respect to Y is equal
to some function f of X that's a
perfectly good differential equation and
we already discussed last time that the
solution that is the function y is going
to be the antiderivative or the integral
of X now for the purposes of today we're
going to consider this problem to be
solved
that is you can always do this you can
always take anti derivatives and for our
purposes now that is for this for now we
only have one technique to find anti
derivatives and that's called
substitution it has a very small variant
which we called advanced guessing and
that works just as well and that's
basically all that you'll ever need to
do as a practical matter these are the
ones you'll face for now ones that you
can actually see what the answer is or
you'll have to make a substitution now
the first tricky example or the first
maybe interesting example of a
differential equation which I'll call
example 2 is going to be the following D
by DX plus X acting on Y is equal to 0
so that's our first differential
equation that we're going to try to
solve
apart from this standard antiderivative
approach
this operation here has has a name this
is actually has a name it's called the
annihilation operator and it's called
that in in quantum mechanics and there's
a corresponding creation operator where
you change the sign from plus to minus
and this is one of the simplest
differential equations the reason why
it's studied in quantum mechanics at all
is that it has very simple solutions
that you can just write out so we're
going to solve this this equation it's
the one that governs the ground state of
the harmonic oscillator
alright so it has a lot of fancy words
associated with it but it's a fairly
simple differential equation it works
perfectly by the method that we're going
to propose so the first step in the
solution is just to rewrite the equation
by putting the the one of the terms on
the right hand side so this is dy/dx is
equal to minus x times y now here is
where you see the difference between
this type of equation and the previous
type in the previous equation we just
had a function of X on the right hand
side but here the rate of change depends
on both x and y so it's not clear at all
that we can solve this kind of equation
but there is a remarkable trick which
works very well in this case which is to
use multiplication to use this idea of
differentials that we talked about last
time namely we divide by y and x DX so
now we've separated the equation we've
separated out the differentials and
what's going to be important for us is
that the left hand side is expressed
solely in terms of Y and the right hand
side is expressed solely in terms of
X will go through this in careful detail
so now the idea is if you've set up the
equation in terms of differentials as
opposed to ratios of differentials or
rates of change now I can use liveness
notation and integrate these
differentials take their anti
derivatives and we know what each of
these is namely the left-hand side is
just well that's tough okay
yeah I had to have an au pair who
actually did a lot of Taekwondo and in
fact she could she could definitely
defeat any of you in any encounter I
promise you okay anyway so let's go back
we have we want to take the
antiderivative of this so remember so
remember this is the antiderivative the
function whose derivative is 1 over Y
and now there's a slight novelty here
here we're differentiating the variables
X and here we're differentiating the
variable is y so the antiderivative here
is natural log of Y and the
antiderivative on the other side is
minus x squared over 2 and they differ
by a constant so we have this
relationship here right now that's
almost the end of the story we have to
exponentiate to express Y in terms of X
so e to the log Y is equal to e to the
minus x squared over 2 plus C and now I
can rewrite that as Y is equal to I'll
write it as a eetu the minus x squared
over 2 where a is equal to e to the C
and incidentally we're just taking the
case why positive here we'll talk about
what happens when y is negative in in a
few minutes all right so here's the
answer to the question almost except for
this fact that I picked out why why
positive really the solution is y is
equal to any multiple of e to the minus
x squared over two any constant a a
positive negative or 0 any constant will
do and we should double-check that to
make sure if you take d by DX of Y right
that's going to be d baah so that's
going to be a times D by DX of e to the
minus x squared over 2 and now by the
chain rule you can see that this is a
times the fact of minus X that's the
derivative of the exponent with respect
to x times the exponential and now you
just rearrange that that's minus x times
y all right so it does check these are
solutions to the equation the a didn't
matter
it didn't matter whether it was positive
or negative
this function is is known as the normal
distribution so it fits beautifully with
a lot of probability and other
probabilistic interpretation of quantum
mechanics this is sort of the where the
particle is alright so next what I'd
like to do is just go through the method
in general and point out when it works
and then I'll make a few comments just
to make sure that you understand the
technicalities of dealing with constants
and so forth so first of all the general
method of separation of variables and
here's when it works it works
when you're faced with a differential
equation of the form f of X times G of Y
that's the situation that we had and
I'll just illustrate that just to remind
you here here's our equation it's in
that form and the function f of X is
minus X and the function G of Y is just
Y and now the way the method works is
this separation step from here to here
this is the key step alright this is the
only sort of conceptually a remarkable
step which all has to do with the fact
that Leibniz fixed his notations up so
that this works perfectly and so that
involves taking the Y over so dividing
by G of Y and multiplying by DX it's
comfortable because it feels like
ordinary arithmetic
even though these are differentials and
then we just anti-differentiate so we
have a function H which is the integral
of dy G of Y and we have another
function which is f note they have
functions of completely different
variables here integral of f of X
DX now in our example we did that we
carried out this anti differentiation
and this function turned out to the log
Y and this function turned out to be
minus x squared over two and then we
write the relationship which is that if
these are both anti derivatives of the
same thing then they have to differ by a
constant or in other words H of Y has to
equal to f of X plus C where C is
constant now notice that this kind of
equation is what we call an implicit
equation it's not quite a formula for y
directly it defines Y implicitly that's
that top line up here right that's the
implicit equation in order to make it an
explicit equation which is what is
underneath what I have to do is take the
inverse so I write it as Y is equal to H
inverse of f of X plus C now in real
life the calculus part is often pretty
easy and it can be quite messy to do the
inverse operation so sometimes we just
leave it alone in the implicit form but
it's also satisfying sometimes to write
it in the in the final form here
okay now I want to give you a few little
pieces of commentary before for those of
you who walked in a little bit late this
will all be on the web so just a few
pieces of commentary so if you like some
some remarks the first remark is that I
could have written could have written
natural log of absolute y is equal to
minus x squared over two plus C alright
we we learned last time that the
antiderivative works also for the
negative value so this would work for y
not equal to zero both for positive and
negative values and you can see that
that would have captured most of the
rest of the solution namely absolute y
would be equal to ay e to the minus x
squared over two by the same reasoning
as before and then that would mean that
Y was equal to plus or minus a e to the
minus x squared over two which is really
just what we got right because in fact I
didn't bother with this because actually
in most in it and the reason why I'm
going through this by the way carefully
this time is that you're going to be
faced with this very frequently the
exponential function comes up all the
time and so therefore you want to be
completely comfortable dealing with it
so so this time I had the positive a
well the negative a fits in either this
way or I can throw it in because I know
that that's going to work that way
but of course I double check to be to be
confident now this still leaves out one
value so this still leaves out so if you
like what I have here now is a is equal
to plus or minus capital a the the
capital A one being a positive one but
this still leaves out one
case which is why equals zero which is
an extremely boring but solution but
nevertheless a solution to this problem
if you plug in zero here for y you get
zero if you plug in zero here for y you
get that these two sides are equal right
zero equals zero it's not a very
interesting answer to the question but
it's still an answer and so y equals
zero is left out well that's not so
surprising that we missed that solution
because in the process of carrying out
these operations I divided by Y right I
did that I did that right here so that's
what happens if you're going to do
various nonlinear operations in
particular if you're going to divide by
something if it happens to be zero
you're going to miss that solution or
you might have problems with that
solution we have to live with that
because we want to get ahead and we want
to get the formulas for for various
solutions all right so that's the first
remark that I wanted to make and now the
second one is also well it's almost
related to what I was just discussing
right here that I'm erasing and that's
the following I could have also written
I could have also written log y plus c1
is equal to minus x squared over 2 plus
C 2 where C 1 and C 2 are different
constants when I'm faced with this
antidifferentiation
I just taught you last time that you
want to have an arbitrary constant here
and there in both slots so I perfectly
well could have written this down but
notice that I can rewrite this as log Y
is equal to minus x squared over 2 plus
C 2 minus C 1 I can subtract and then if
I just combine these two guys together
and name them see I have a different
constant in other words it's superfluous
and redundant to
to arbitrary constants here because they
can always be combined into one so two
constants are superfluous can always be
combined so we just never do it this
first way it's just extra writing it's a
waste of time there's one other subtle
remark which which you won't actually
appreciate until you've done several
problems in this direction which is that
the constant appears additive here in
this first solution to the problem but
when I do this nonlinear operation of
exponentiation it now becomes a
multiplicative constant and so in
general there's a free constant
somewhere in the problem but it's not
always an additive constant it's only an
additive constant right at the first
step when you take the antiderivative
and then after that when you do all your
other nonlinear operations it can turn
into anything at all so you should
always expect it to be something
slightly more interesting than an
additive constant all occasionally it
stays an additive constant
the last little bit of commentary that I
want to make just goes back to the
original problem here which is right
here the example one and I want to solve
it even though this is simple-minded but
example one via separation so that you
see variables so that you see what it
does the situation is this
and the separation just means you put
the DX on the other side so this is dy
is equal to f of X DX and then we
integrate and if the antiderivative of
dy is just Y so this is the solution to
the problem and it's just what we wrote
before it's just a just a funny notation
in it and it comes to the same thing as
the antiderivative
ok so now we're going to go on to a
trickier problem a trickier example we
need one or two more just to get some
practice with this method everybody
happy so far question
yeah so the question is how do we deal
with this ambiguity I'm summarizing very
very briefly what what I heard well you
know sometimes a is bigger than zero
sometimes a is less than zero sometimes
is not so there's a name for this this
guy which is that this is what's called
the general solution in other words the
whole family of solutions is the answer
to the question now it could be that
you're given extra information if you're
given extra information that might be
and this is very typical in such
problems you have the rate of change of
the function which is what we've given
but you might also have the place where
it starts which would be say it starts
at 3 all right now if you have that
extra piece of information then you can
nail down exactly which function it is
all right if you do that if you plug in
3 you see that a times e to the minus 0
squared over 2 is equal to 3 so a is
equal to 3 and the answer is Y is equal
to 3 e to the minus x squared over 2 and
similarly if it's negative if this if it
starts out negative it'll stay negative
for instance if it starts out 0 it'll
stay 0 this particular function here so
the so the answer to your question is
how do you deal with the ambiguity the
answer is that you you simply say what
the solution is in the solution is not
one function it's a family of functions
it's a list and you have to have a
parameter known as a parameter and that
parameter gets nailed down if you tell
me more information about the function
not the rate of change but something
about the values of the function
here that's the the general solution is
this solution and I'm showing you here
that you could get to most of the
general solution there's one thing
that's left out namely the case equals
zero this so in other words I would not
go through this method I would only use
this which is simpler but then I have to
understand that I haven't gotten all the
solutions this way I'm going to need to
throw in all the rest of the solutions
so in the back of your head you always
have to have something like this in mind
so that you can generate all the
solutions this is very suggestive right
the restriction it turns out that the
restriction a greater than zero is
superfluous is unnecessary but that we
only get by further thought and by
checking other another question over
here the aim of differential equations
is to solve them just as with algebraic
equations they they usually differential
equations are telling you something
about the balance between an
acceleration and and a velocity if
you're you know you have a falling
object it might have a resistance
there's it's it's telling you something
so actually sometimes in applied
problems formulating what differential
equation describes the situation is very
important in order to see that that's
the right thing you have to have solved
it to see that it fits the data that
you're that you're getting the question
is can you solve for X instead of Y the
answer is sure you can that that's the
same thing as so so that would be the
inverse function of the function that
we're officially looking for but yeah
it's legal in other words oftentimes
we're stuck with just the implicit some
implicit formula and sometimes we're
stuck with a formula X as a function of
Y versus Y as a function of X that's not
it the way in which
the function is specified is something
that can be complicated as you'll see in
the next example it's not necessarily
the best thing to think about a function
y as a function of X well in the example
the fourth example alright we're going
to go on and do our next example here
okay so the third example is going to be
taken a kind of geometry problem I'll
draw a picture of it suppose you have a
curve with the following property if you
take a point on the curve and you take
the Ray you take the ray from the origin
to the curve whoops well that's not
going to be the one that I want I think
I'm going to want something which is
steeper because what I'm going to insist
is that the tangent line be twice as
steep as the as the ray from the origin
so in other words slope of tangent line
equals twice slope of Ray from origin
alright so that's the slope of this
orange line is twice the slope of the
pink line now these kinds of geometric
problems can be written very succinctly
with rates of with differential
equations namely it's just the following
dy DX that's the slope of the tangent
line is equal to well remember what the
slope of this ray is if this point I
need a notation if this point is X comma
Y which is a point on the curve so the
slope of this pink line is what
Y over X so if it's twice it there's the
equation okay now we only have one
method for solving these equations so
let's use it it says two separate
variables so I write dy divided by Y
here is equal to 2 DX divided by x
that's the basic separation that's the
procedure that we're always going to use
and now if I integrate that I find that
on the right hand side I have a
logarithm of Y and on the left hand up
and so on left-hand side I have the
logarithm of Y on the right hand side I
have twice the logarithm of X plus a
constant so let's see what happens to
this example this is an implicit
equation and of course we have the
problems of the plus and minus signs
which I'm not going to worry about until
later so let's exponentiate and see what
happens we get e to the log Y is equal
to e to the 2 log X plus C so again this
is y on the left hand side and on the
right hand side if you think about it
for a second it's e to the log x squared
which is x squared so this is x squared
and then there's an e to the C so that's
another one of these a factors here all
right it is equal to e to the C
so the answer is well I'll draw the
picture and I'm going to cheat as I did
before we skipped the case y- we really
only did the case y+ so far but if you
think about it for a second and we'll
check it in a second you're going to get
all of these parabolas here so the
solution is this family of functions and
they can be bending down as well as up
so these are the solutions to this
equation every single one of these
curves has the property that if you pick
a point on it the tangent line has twice
the slope of the Ray to the origin and
this the the formula if you like of the
general solution is y equals ax squared
a is any any constant question
yeah so again it so so first of all one
thing so they're they're two approaches
to this one is to check it and make sure
that it's right when a formula works for
some family values sometimes it works
for others but another one is to realize
that these things will usually work out
this way because in this argument here I
allowed the absolute value all right and
that would have been a perfectly legal
thing for me to do I could have put in
absolute values here in which case I
would have gotten that the absolute
value of this was equal to that and now
you see I've covered the plus and minus
cases all right so it's that same idea
this implies that Y is equal to either
plus a x squared or minus a x squared
depending on which which sign you pick
so that allows me for the curves above
and curves below because because it's
really true that the antiderivative here
is this function it's defined for y- so
let's just double check in this case
what's happening we have the y equals ax
squared and we want to compute dy DX to
make sure that it satisfies the equation
that I started out with and what I see
here is that this is two ax and now I'm
going to write this in a suggestive way
I'm going to write it as 2 ax squared
divided by X and sure enough this is 2y
divided by x it does not matter whether
a it works for a positive a negative a
equals zero it's okay
again we didn't pick up by this method
the a equals zero case and that's not
surprising because we divided by Y
there's another thing to watch out about
about this example so there's another
warning which I have to give you and
this is a subtlety which you definitely
won't get to in in any detail until you
get to a higher level ordinary
differential equations course but I do
want to warn you about it right now
which is that if you look at the
equation you need to watch out that it's
undefined at x equals 0 its undefined at
x equals 0 we also divided by X and X is
also a problem now that actually has an
important consequence which is that
strangely knowing the value here and
knowing the rate of change doesn't
specify this function this is bad and
it's violates one of our pieces of
intuition and what's going wrong is that
the rate of change was was not specified
it's undefined at x equals 0 so there's
a problem here and in fact if you think
carefully about what this function is
doing it could come in on one branch and
leave on a completely different branch
it doesn't really have to obey any rule
across x equals 0
so you should really be thinking these
things as rays emanating from the from
the origin the origin was a special
point in the whole geometric problem
rather than as being complete parabolas
that that's a very subtle point I don't
expect you to to be able to say anything
about it but I just want to warn you
that you know it really is true that
when X is equal to 0 there's a problem
for this function for this for this
differential equation
all right so now well so so now let me
say our next problem next example which
is just another geometry question so
here's example 4 I'm just going to use
the example that we've already got
because there's only so much time left
here the fourth example is to take the
curves curves perpendicular to the
parabolas this is another geometry
problem and by specifying that the
curves are perpendicular to these
parabolas I'm telling you what their
slope is so let's think about that
what's the new equation nude if you Q is
the following it's that the slope is
equal to the negative reciprocal of the
slope of the tangent line of tangent to
the parabola ok so that's the that's the
equation that's actually fairly easy to
write down because it's minus 1/2 Y
divided by X right that's the slope of
the parabola right to Y divided by X
so let's rewrite that now this is the X
goes in the numerator so it's minus x
over 2y and now I want to solve this one
well again there's only one technique
which is we're going to separate
variables and we separate the
differentials here so we get 2y dy
equals minus X DX that's just looking at
the equation that I have which is right
over here dy DX is equal to minus x over
2y and cross multiplying to get this and
now I can take the antiderivative this
is y squared and the antiderivative over
here is minus x squared over 2 plus a
constant and so the solutions are x
squared over 2 plus y squared is equal
to some C some constant C now this time
things don't work the same and they you
can't expect them always to work the
same I claimed that this must be true
but unfortunately I cannot insist that
every C will work as you can see here
only the positive numbers C can work
here so the picture is that something
slightly different happened here and you
have to live with this is that sometimes
not all the constants will work because
there's more to the problem than just
the anti-differentiation and here there
are fewer answers rather than more
answers in the other case we had to add
in some answers here we have to take
them away some of them don't make any
sense
and the only ones we can get are the
ones which are of this four
where this is say some radius squared
well maybe I shouldn't call it a radius
I'll just call it a parameter a squared
and these are of course ellipses and you
can see that the ellipses the length
here is what it's it's the square root
of 2a and the the semi axis vertical
semi axis is a so this is the kind of
ellipse that we've got and if I draw it
on the on the previous diagram I think
it's somewhat suggestive here they're
ellipses are kind of eggs they're a
little bit longer than they are high and
they go like this and if I drew them
pretty much right they should be making
right angles at all these places
okay last little bit here again to be
you've got to be very careful with these
solutions and so there's under warning
here too
so let's take a look at the this is the
implicit solution to the equation and
this is the one that tells us what the
shape is but we can also have the
explicit solution and if I solve for the
explicit solution its y is equal to
either plus square root of a squared
minus x squared over 2 or Y is equal to
minus the square root of a squared minus
x squared over 2 right these are the the
explicit solutions and now we notice
something that we should have noticed
before which is that an ellipse is not a
function it's it's only the top half if
you like that's giving you a solution to
this equation or maybe the bottom half
that's giving you a solution to the
equation so the one over here this one
is the top halves and this one over here
as the bottom halves and there's
something else that's interesting which
is that we have a problem at y equals 0
y equals 0 is where X is a square root
of 2 times a that's when we get to this
end here and what happens is the
solution comes around and it stops it
has a vertical slope vertical slope and
the solution stops but really that's not
so unreasonable after all look at the
formula there was a Y in the denominator
here when y is equal to zero the slope
should be infinite and so you know this
this this this equation is just giving
us what it geometrically and intuitively
should be giving us at that at that
stage
okay so that is the introduction to
ordinary differential equations again
there's only one technique which is
we're not done yet though you know we
have a whole four minutes left and we're
going to review it now so fortunately
this review is very short fortunately
for you I hand it out to you exactly
what you're going to be covering on the
test and it's what's printed here but
there's a whole two pages of discussion
and I want to give you very very
clear-cut instructions here this is
usually the hardest test of this course
people usually do terribly on it and I'm
going to try to stop that by making it a
little bit easier and now here's here's
what we're going to do I'm telling you
exactly what type of problems they're
going to be on the test these are these
six it's also written on your sheet your
handout it's also just what was asked
last on last year's test you should go
and you should look at last year's test
and see what types of problems they are
we I really really I'm going to ask the
same question so the same type of
questions alright not the same questions
all right so that's what's going to
happen on the test and let me just tell
you say one thing which is the main
theme of the class and I will I will
open up we'll have time for one question
after that the main theme of this unit
is simply the following that information
about derivative and sometimes maybe the
second derivative tells us information
about F itself
and that's just what we were doing here
with ordinary differential equations and
that was what we were doing way at the
beginning when we did approximations